ich würde mich sehr freuen wenn ihr euch
dieses video hier komplett anschauen
würde denn ich hab mir sehr viel mehr im
schnitt gegeben viel spaß und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen blog ich mache
gerade eine master award beim honig
blüten maske und hoffe dass ich da nicht
mehr so hätte ich bin nur wenige minuten
später ist nicht so geklappt tag
übrigens ein laserschwert bestellt und
mitgenommen nach holland und das hat
meine volle funktion dass man sachen ein
sagen kann und dann kann man mit dem
besaß man ein gesagt haben keine
absprachen lernen da die batterien ist
leer
sandra stinkt das scheiße das lade ich
für video weiter
[Musik]
du bist ein arschloch liebe meinen
youtube-kanal maxi haben die challenge
für dich legt nicht mal auf dem bau in
jetzt packt die hände hinter deinem
rücken und versucht hoch zu kommen ohne
dich auf die seite zu drehen sondern nur
einfach hochkommen
[Musik]
es geht nämlich nicht klar oder mach du
mal ich hab dich doch gewinner als wenn
das wirklich nicht generell nichts gegen
solche besucher gesehen hatte dass es
schwer ist alter es geht nicht die
daumen hoch das ist auch die challenge
hat sie sich auf dem bauch auf dem boden
liegt und jetzt muss zu hoch kommen ohne
dich rüber zu drehen oder über die seite
auch zu stehen
[Musik]
ok es war auf jeden fall recht schönes
wetter heute morgen genau von holland
allerdings hat sich jetzt mit
hinzugezogen
das ist aufwendig aber wir werden
trotzdem war ich rausgehen wie vor
allerdings herausgeben wollte ich dann
auch noch ein paar fragen stellen
bruder dies nicht an ich fühle mich hier
wie der boss also sage ich habe mir ein
paar fragen aufgeschrieben die duh
beantwortung ist das okay ist es über
den berg kürzer als zu fuß
es ist nachts kälter als draußen alte
brötchen schmecken waren besser als
lecker oder mach zwei anzüge schneller
als auf schienen das blau grüner als
gelb sitzt man rechtssicherer als im
flugzeug ein tisch hat vier beine
besonders das linke richtig ist der ofen
genauso vorne wie hoch und die letzte
frage was der unterschied zwischen einem
vogel
ich stehe hier nur mit zur vollidioten
jetzt draußen gehen habe ich auf jeden
fall noch einige polizist vorbereitete
mir beispielsweise im basketball wird
mit dem ich dieses komische machen
sollte dass man die kamera auf dem boden
stelle kommt braucht man speist den hof
und dann kommt auf den kopf wir wollten
vielleicht ins aquarium gehen also nicht
ins aquarium rein sondern in so einem
fischer museum oder sowas vielleicht
fisch museum
[Musik]
zwei flaschen hat man das beiden
dahinter ab jetzt hoch das bein und
jetzt das andere nach hinten das und ein
linkes bein auf der linken seite von
einer therme nach hinten es wird so hoch
kommen ein paar sekunden später hätte
wirklich nicht weg wir sind alle gruppen
als anderson geht das gar nicht lachen
muss ich und die laterne herum gekommen
als die versuchen max sitze dritter weg
zu sehen ihr seid gehen es gibt andere
stets vor der kamera
apa
zurzeit nicht objekt wir machen jetzt
die basketball challenge freunde das
heißt ich leg die kamera hierhin wir
gucken alle in die kamera während den
ball hoch und bei dem auf dem kopf mit
der ersten opfer
[Applaus]
ich hab's schiffsleute jüngers reich
[Musik]
belohnt diese stelle angekommen an der
strandpromenade meine lieben freunde es
ist überhaupt nicht windig stars der
stand auf jeden fall bin ich jetzt
andere angefragt und wir gehen jetzt ein
sea life also muss sie haben auch
wenigen ziele das erste was man sieht
dass eine kuh dann hast du schon bock
die ganze wasserschlangen zu sehen dann
hat man mal angst vor schlangen und hat
gerade die verkäuferin vorne die
holländerin ist hat sich auf eher
deutsch englisch gefragt als der water
snacks und die sonne und der mond come
to you und andere nur so wat de gavan
als die aussehen dagegen bis zu einem
china wolle brocken die sich dort wie
eine kuh die fische sind einfach aus als
wären sie alle schlafen nur die schön
einfach auf der stelle trat mac hat die
ganze zeit dass das hier für sie nicht
17 euro wert ist nicht mal 50 cent man
diese fast verschämt in der nordsee und
räte doch so ein ding drauf oder auch
sonntag oder halt auch so ein ding
einfach von human ecke schaut euch mal
vor ihr schwingt sondern knackte euch da
eure füße arbeiter das ist jetzt eine
antwort hier trainieren aber ich schwöre
jeder zoo das ist die laser kanone hat
immer ein gehege wo nichts drin ist
einfach nur so hey das ist eigentlich
das rabatt der der ist nicht mehr da
die gar der mehr als ich alter wenn der
einmal zwinkert jetzt dann ist abonnent
analog zu
[Musik]
ich hoffe jetzt was soll denn hier jagen
vega steine oder was der einfach absolut
gar keinen bock eine schlange seit der
schönste für ständig hier gesehen haben
voll krass dass sagen wir auch hier
bruder wir denken die ganze zeit de ist
nicht echt ich dachte euro für eine
leinwand das ist echt mein gott oh mein
gott da ist einfach irgendein rund fisch
mit summe horn von ausländern also drauf
was ein armes leben von den quallen die
schöne einfach in unserem kleinen kreis
werden mit einer strömung im kreisgebiet
werden verschiedene angeleuchtet so also
klar irgendwo chillig aber ich brauch
nicht sogar der grund warum herzen
dieses ziel auf gegangen sind war
eigentlich das für pinguine sehen
wollten und welche tiere sind nicht hier
pinguine die sind schon schlafen in
ihrem häuschen mit auch jetzt eigentlich
da vorher film aber ich habe alle sind
übrigens auch schon fertig auseinander
die frist immer noch ihr komisches
erich luca ob die vielleicht kann er
wollte die an dem corsa gold dann hast
du bist scheiße
ja und diese alle irgendwie extrem müde
und ich bin nach unten ganzen anderen
und ich komme mir alle und plötzlich
modelle in der presse das ist eine späte
bestimmt alter dann wachst du denn da
weg
wo ist anderer seite sie hatten kassen
zauberte gelernten sie uns jetzt zeigen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
sandra lande hat uns gerade erzählt daß
dies über alles passt nicht wenn man
irgendwie mit denen den fingernägeln an
der tafel kratzt oder irgend sowas
sondern der mann was sofort um heinz
baum gefallen oder was hast du so
beispielsweise geschrieben gerne mit
justin bieber fan gruppe bei ihm kaputt
late night snack pizza tonno mit
knoblauchsoße beschissen
dann aber wenn du jetzt nicht sagt
sollten die leute dem video an daumen
hoch gehen und nicht abonnieren
sehr gut an einer stelle wird den
heutigen blog jetzt auch beenden meine
lieben freunde dass auch unser letzter
tag in holland
die letzten beiden tage habe ich hab's
zusammengepackt zu einem blog ich weiß
gar nicht bin ich glaube vernünftig
überhaupt erkennen kann morgen früh
fahren auf jeden fall wieder zurück nach
deutschland deswegen will ich den blog
an der stelle schon mal beenden wie gar
schon gesagt hat euch gefallen und das
gerne daumen hoch da abonnieren kanal
und im video wollt ihr mehr auf lok
stand schreibt die kommentare und jetzt
kommt's drauf
[Musik]